je voudrais commencer par vous raconter
une anecdote j'ai une sœur cadette qui a
18 mois de moins que moi et quand nous
étions jeunes étudiantes nous étions
très souvent ensemble et j'avais été
frappé à l'époque parce que des
personnes qui ne savaient pas qu'on
était sœurs nous disait souvent mais
c'est vous c'est vous ce que vous
ressemblez ou vous êtes jumelles et
d'autres qui savaient pourtant qu'on
était sœur me disait ah mais vous
ressemblez pas du tout vous êtes très
différente donc j'avais trouvé ça
bizarre qu'on puisse selon le cas nous
trouver très ressemblante ou très
différente et ça m'avait fait toucher du
doigt très tôt que la différence c'est
donc une notion très subjective et très
variable en fonction des personnes alors
je me présente je suis une femme je suis
blanche je suis française Tarbes
d'origine et tout d'adoption pour être
plus précise je suis salutéieu dans une
frattererie de trois avec donc une sœur
cadette et un frère aîné je suis Marie
je suis maman et belle- mère aussi je
suis
hétérosexuelle je suis jeune ou vieille
c'est selon j'ai 49 ans donc c'est à
vous de me dire si vous me placez dans
les jeunes ou dans les vieilles je suis
fonctionnaire je suis en bonne santé et
valide je ne suis ni tatoué ni percé je
suis désordonnée je suis
hâté je mesure moins de 1,90 je pèse
plus de 40 kg je suis fidèle je suis
procrastinatrice je suis suis de gauche
je suis omnivore tendance carnivore je
suis cartésienne je suis optimiste
chacune de ces caractéristiques me
définit et elle peut donc bien sûr me
différencier par rapport aux autres
êtres humains sur cette planète par
rapport à vous par exemple et il en est
de même pour chacun d'entre
nous certaines de ces caractéristiques
vous ont peut-être intérieurement fait
réagir plus que
d'autres décenchant peut-être un a
priori positif ou un peu moins positif
alors ne me dites pas non c'est
automatique nous avons tous des préjugés
quelques mots seulement en plus bien sûr
de ce qui se voi euh crée un sentiment
positif ou négatif certains plus que
d'autres et c'est très personnel
certaines de ces caractéristiques comme
vous le savez peuvent créer des
phénomènes de rejet de de discrimination
parfois même de violence ces réactions
pent un nom sexisme racisme
xénophobie homophobie
jeunisme d'autres ne portent pas
nécessairement de nom euh mais pour
autant elles peuvent être bien réelles
par rapport physique par exemple auid au
poids ou à la taille par rapport au
handicap ou encore vis-à-vis de vos
idées ou de vos choix de vie comme le
dit Arben Gou la nature crée des
différences et la société en fait des
inégalités donc j'ai un long parcours de
plus de 25 ans dans les ressources
humaines l'humain et toutes ces
différences a été au au cœur de ce
parcours à l'université pendant 10 ans
j'ai été DRH puis j'ai été chargé de la
coordination de la responsabilité
sociale de l'université la RSU à ce
titre je m'intéresse à la diversité et à
la lutte contre tous les types de de
discrimination et d'inégalité et je
m'occupe notamment de l'inclusion du
handicap alors en tant que
correspondante handicap pour les
personnels de l'université je suis au
cœur de la problématique de la
discrimination vis-à-vis du handicap une
discrimination qui est bien réelle voilà
une différence qui crée des rejets des
stéréotypes des a priori lutter contre
cela ce n'est pas facile intégrer les
personnes en situation de handicap dans
le monde du travail ça n ite une vraie
volonté et des efforts au quotidien
savez-vous par exemple que la loi pour
l'égalité des droits et des chances la
participation et la citoyenneté des
personnes en situation de handicap date
déjà du 11 février 2005 a donc plus de
10 ans elle était elle-même
l'aboutissement d'un long processus et
pourtant nous sommes encore loin de
l'égalité en tant que DRH j'ai été
souvent amené à recruter pour moi-même
pour mes équipes ou avec d'autres
managers et j'ai pu observer que
certains ont tendance à recruter plutôt
des personnes qui leur ressemblent et
d'autres plutôt des personnes assez
différentes donc recruter plutôt comme
soi ça peut avoir son intérêt garantir
la réussite du recrutement permettre la
l'intégration plus facile de la personne
dans l'équipe ou même lui permettre de
s'adapter plus facilement à son propre
mode de management et puis recruter
plutôt différent de soi ça participe
plutôt d'une volonté de diversité
d'enrichissement dans l'équipe
rechercher une complémentarité en terme
de compétences ou même en terme de mode
de fonctionnement donc je ne crois pas
qu'il y a une méthode qui garantisse la
réussite du recrutement mais voilà en
tout cas deux façons de faire et il est
peut-être intéressant de se demander ce
que l'on cherche et comment l'
fonctionne avant de
recruter pendant ma formation en tant
que coach chez coach Academy on nous a
invité à définir notre mission et à
cibler une clientèle donc à l'époque je
me suis demandé est-ce que pour être
plus performant il vaut mieux coacher
des clients plutôt proches de moi qui me
ressemblent du même milieu pour mieux
les comprendre pour que l'accompagnement
soit plus efficace ou au contraire
coacher des personnes très différentes
issu d'un autre monde professionnel
alors personnellement j'ai accompagné
des personnes très différentes dans des
objectifs personnels et professionnels
et je ne peux pas vraiment dire ce qui
marche le mieux pour moi le coaching
c'est un accompagnement lucide et
bienveillant à base de questions et
d'écoute qui marche avec tout types de
clients mais ce que je peux dire c'est
que j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à
accompagner des personnes très
différentes et je peux témoigner que ça
marche en dehors de mon parcours
professionnel la différence est
également une richesse dans ma vie
personnelle autour de moi parmi mes amis
mes connaissances il a bien sûr des gens
très différents avec toutes les
caractéristiques possible et aussi des
gens qui me ressemblent j'ai par exemple
beaucoup d'amis qui ont fait les mêmes
études que moi qui sont du même milieu
donc je dirais qu'ils me ressemblent
nous sommes proches et c'est super parmi
eux j'ai une amie qui est très croyante
et qui m'a un jour demandé d'être la
marine de son deuxème fils alors comme
je vous l'ai dit en introduction je suis
attée et je ne suis pas baptisée donc je
me suis un petit peu enfin un peu
réfléchi et puis finalement j'ai accepté
donc aujourd'hui moi hâé et pas baptisé
je suis marine devant Dieu et je trouve
ça
top j'ai aussi une amie d'enfance très
différente de moi c'est une artiste elle
est comédienne écrivaine je la connais
on se connaitt depuis qu'on a 9 ans et
je l'ai accompagné tout ce temps et elle
a fait des choix de vie très très
différents des mien je pense que je dois
en partie à cette amitié depuis
l'enfance mon ouverture à la différence
je suis maman et belle maman aussi donc
j'ai deux filles adolescentes et une
grande belle fille qui rentre dans la
vie active mais des filles elles sont
très différentes elles ont de ans de
différence elle ne se ressemble pas
tellement ni physiquement ni sur le plan
du caractère et je trouve ça génial euh
oui je je trouve cette différence et
aussi un enrichissement en tant que
maman parce que ça m'oblige à à me
remettre en question à adapter ma
posture mon discours mon écoute ce qui
marche avec l'une ne fonctionne pas avec
l'autre et je prends ça aussi pour une
chance et pour un
enrichissement je suis mariée et en
couple depuis plus de 20 ans donc j'ai
il y a longtemps fait le choix de mon
partenaire dans mon cas le choix de
quelqu'un plutôt différent de moi dans
le fond mais vous si vous êtes en couple
vous avez aussi fait un choix comment
l'avez-vous fait avez-vous choisi
quelqu'un qui vous ressemble plutôt
proche de vous ou bien quelqu'un de
plutôt différent plutôt complémentaire
vous avez certainement remarqué qu'il y
a des proverbes pour nous dire qui se
ressemble ça semble et d'autres pour
nous dire que les opposés s'attirent
donc le lesquel vous parle le plus
lesquels vous correspondent le mieux là
encore je ne crois pas qu'il y a un
meilleur choix qui garantirait que ça
marche mieux plus longtemps ou pour tous
mais en tout cas il y a une tendance il
n a pas de vérité mais il y a
certainement une tendance naturelle qui
nous porte vers l'un ou vers l'autre ou
au contraire qui nous
retient donc il est peut-être
intéressant d'en avoir fait l'analyse
personnellement savoir comment l'on
fonctionne pour savoir pour soi ce qui
marche le mieux donc nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui autour du thème humanité
l'humanité est faite de diversité
et vous vers où va votre attirance vers
ce qui vous ressemble et qui vous permet
certainement de vous sentir
immédiatement plus à l'aise plus en
confiance dans votre zone de confort ou
plutôt vers ce qui est différent de vous
et qui certainement vous enrichit je
vous invite à vous poser la question
pour vous dans vos choix en général dans
le choix de vos relations vos choix
culturels vos choix musicaux dans vos
activités en général car dans chaque
domaine de la vie les différences
attirent ou éloignent naturellement
c'est juste une bonne chose de le savoir
de se connaître et d' avoir pris
conscience ça vous donne une sorte de
petite cartographie personnelle qu' est
intéressant d'avoir analysé pour soi pas
nécessairement pour la modifier mais
pour comprendre vers où cela nous porte
pourquoi on se sent naturellement attiré
ou refroidi par telle ou telle personne
et puis ensuite si on a envie de
d'évoluer de changer certains de ns a
prioris c'est intéressant d'avoir fait
cette analyse finement par petite touche
et avec toutes les nuances car oui la
différence
parfois exclu éloigne inquiète fait peur
la couleur de la peau la culture mais
des choses aussi beaucoup plus
anecdotiques que pense a priori un
Marseillais d'un parisien ou même un
toulousin d'un Bordelet et puis beaucoup
d'autres choses encore comme votre
statut si vous êtes marié ou célibataire
si vous êtes si vous avez des enfants ou
si vous n'en avez pas V préférence
sexuelle religieuse politique votre
caractère votre tempérament pour
optimiste il est bien difficile de
comprendre celui qui voit le verre
toujours à moitié vide pour ma part vous
l'avez compris la différence matire elle
m'intéresse elle m'enrichit c'est
certainement une question de caractère
c'est aussi une question d'éducation je
pense que je dois en partie enfin
probablement à mes parents ce cette
curiosité pour ceux que je ne connais
pas et ce goût des autres c'est donc
bien sûr une question de valeur la
différence est une richesse oui si elle
nourrit vos valeurs pour ma part elle
nourrit mes valeurs de tolérance de
générosité et d'optimisme mais vous il
s'agira peut-être de nourrir d'autres
valeurs de combler des valeurs qui sont
importantes pour vous la
curiosité la découverte
l'apprentissage la coopération l'égalité
l'inspiration l'émerveillement et
beaucoup d'autres bien sûr parce que je
ne peux pas toutes les citer si vous
avez bien analysé bien identifié toutes
vos valeurs vous identifierez tout ce
que toutes les différences qu'offre la
grande diversité de l'humanité peuvent
vous apporter personnellement et si vous
faites cette analyse vous verrez que
votre monde est peut-être réduit limité
parce que vous n'allez pas naturellement
vers tel ou tel
différence la différence c'est un
jugement un jugement très personnel donc
comme je l'ai évoqué dans mon
introduction et l'anecdote avec ma sœur
si nous reconnaissons que nous avons des
préjugés nous allons pouvoir les
questionner et peut-être les dépasser
nous côoyons la différence nous allons
pouvoir nous confronter à d'autres
visions à d'autres façons d'être de de
de penser de faire cela pousse à la
remise en question et éventuellement au
changement mais quand on y
réfléchit chacun d'entre nous homme ou
femme noir ou blanc hétéro ou
homo croyant ou aé jeune ou vieux chacun
d'entre nous est avant tout un être
humain et c'est quand même à la base une
ressemblance intrinsèque qui nous unit
en cherchant bien vous trouverez en
chacun un millier de choses qui
ressemble et un millier de choses qui
font la différence certaines ont
simplement pour vous particulièrement
plus d'importance parmi toutes les
caractéristi d'une personne quelles sont
celles que vous remarquez le plus est-ce
dans un sentiment positif curiosité
intérêt attirance ou est dans un
sentiment négatif crainte méfiance recul
soyez lucide qu'est-ce qui vous fait le
plus réagir la différence ou la
ressemblance et est-ce positivement ou
négativement si vous remarquez en
priorité les différences recherchez chez
cette personne tous les points communs
avec vous et si c'est plutôt les
ressemblances recherchez ce qui vous
différencie car ce ne sont pas les
différences qui sont importantes c'est
l'importance que vous leur accorder qui
fait la différence pour conclure je
citerai Paul Valée mettons en commun ce
que nous avons de meilleur et
enrichissonsnous de N Mutu différence
merci de votre accueil et de votre
écoute